hello everyone
it's my pleasure today to welcome you
all to this webinar entitled
advancing targeted protein degradation
research with automated western blotting
my name is hannah maisel i'm the
innovation manager for topchris a
biotechnic brand
and i will be moderating the webinar
today on behalf of biotechne
aurelia bioscience and lab roots
this webinar will be approximately one
hour long
and the agenda today is as follows i
will provide a short introduction to
targeted protein degradation
my colleague carsten will then provide
an explanation of the simple western
technology that underpins the work that
we
will be presented today and then i will
be inviting gary allenby from aurelia
bioscience to present today's research
talk we will be ending with a live panel
q a
so please do submit your questions to us
using the ask a question box throughout
the session
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
i'd like to take this opportunity to
introduce today's speakers and panelists
dr gary allenby will be giving today's
research
presentation gary is the founder and
chief executive officer of aurelia
bioscience
who are a uk-based pre-clinical contract
research organisation specialising in
bioassays and screening
gary gained his phd from edinburgh
university
before moving into the pharmaceutical
industry with physicians at hoffman
laroche
glaxosmithkline and astrazeneca
he brings a wealth of experience in
assay development and implementation
on the panel for today's q a and
providing introductory information on
the products that supported gary's work
are myself hannah maple and my colleague
carsten luke
i manage the targeted protein
degradation range at toccris
and i'm working on development and
commercialization of tools and
technologies to support this growing
research field
dr carsten luck is the field application
science and science manager for protein
simple
carsten has a phd in proteomics from the
tu munich
and has extensive experience in
electrophoresis and other protein
separation methods
carsten is highly experienced in the
simple western platform for automated
western blotting
and will be able to provide a detailed
introduction to this technology
i'd like to open this webinar with a
brief introduction to targeted protein
degradation and protects
this is a relatively new research field
that harnesses the cell's own ubiquitin
proteasome system to selectively
degrade or knock down target proteins
within cells
it is a tremendously powerful approach
with significant potential
both as a research tool modality and for
clinical development
a protac also known as a degrader
is a heterobifunctional small molecule
that contains two ligands
joined by a chemical linker this is
illustrated schematically in this
diagram
one ligand is designed to bind to an e3
ligase enzyme shown here on the left
and the other ligand is specific for a
target protein
shown on the right in green by
simultaneously binding these two
proteins
the protac degrader induces a ternary
complex which can initiate transfer
of ubiquitin onto the surface lysine
residue of the target protein
the cell's proteasome recognizes the
polyubiquitinated target protein as
marked for destruction and degrades it
into small peptide fragments
the degrader or protac itself is not
destroyed and can go on to induce
ubiquitination of further target protein
molecules
the process is therefore classed as
catalytic which means that only a very
small dose of degrader is required to
elicit a strong
and sustained response
we are building our portfolio to support
researchers working in this field
from a number of different angles as
illustrated on this slide
for researchers investigating each
ligase biology
or screening for new ecoligase ligands
we have the leading range of easy ligase
and related proteins
for researchers wanting to test the
greater technology
or develop their own degraders we have a
suite of chemical tools available
the target validation in the space we
have commercialized the tag
degradation platform and finally for
all degraded development workflows
appropriate assays are critical
and will be the subject of today's talk
bringing all of this together this slide
presents biotechnic's complete solution
the targeted protein degradation
research and the flagship product lines
that support
each aspect of this workflow
i'm going to finish here by providing
you with the link to our targeted
protein degradation home page
www.topchris.com forward slash tpd
where you'll be able to find more
information on all of the workflow
and each product line as well as
supporting literature
animations and videos explaining the
technology in more detail
and also our new protac panel builder
tool
for requesting bespoke panels of
chemical building blocks for your
degrader discovery program
with this i would like to pass you on to
my colleague
dr carsten luc who will be providing an
overview
of the automated western blotting
technology used for today's research
talk
over to you carson thanks a lot hannah
for the
nice introduction as introduced
by hannah my name is dr carson rick i'm
the affairs and science manager for emea
i'm with protein simple by technique for
more than 10 years and first i would
like
again to thank you for attending this
webinar
and today it is my pleasure to introduce
you to the simple western technology
the new gold standard in western
plotting
proteins are our core and we share this
with the rnd system and the novus brand
both r d system and novus provide a wide
variety of proteins and antibodies
to help support your research protein
simple provides the analytical tools
designed to make your protein analysis
simpler
what you see here might be really
familiar to you
this is the pain you feel and must live
day by day whilst using the western plot
technology
on top left you see inverted smile
effect
below you see bubbles in your transfer
arm anyhow the transfer you got an
unknown transfer efficiency
the picture on the right you see this is
the gear
you need a lot of gear and
at the end using the western blood
technology
it is semi-quantitative at its best
and as you know the western blood
technology requires
a lot of manual steps many steps mean
many sources for issues and errors
meaning many things which can go wrong
and it takes a long time and i repeat
myself here it is at its best
semi-quantitative
and my question to you now is um do you
know
when the western plot was invented
it was 1979
it's still used in the same way
yes it is still um
a source which you can use to gain good
results
and it's still used heavily or in a lot
of laps
but let me ask you one question are you
still
using your walkman the walkman was
invented as well
1979 and i personally i don't know
so many people which are still using
their walkman
so they nowadays use a mobile phone
where they stream their music
or have their m or their mp3 files on it
so um i would like you to welcome to the
21st century
welcome to the simple western technology
so our technology is easy to use and
gives you quantitative results in three
hours
here you prepare your samples literally
the same way as for a traditional
western plot
you dilute your samples and you denature
them by heat
the main difference is that you don't
load your samples on a sds gel
rm and you plug them afterwards here
you load three microliters of your
sample along with the primary antibody
and secondary antibody
in our plate for secondary antibodies
you can either choose the ones for nir
or ir fluorescent detection
or hrp coupled ones for
chemiluminescence detection
the plate itself is pre-filled with the
separation reagents
if you choose chemiluminescence for
detection you need to add as well
luminal and peroxide
after plate preparation you spin the
plate to get rid of bubbles
next you peel off the protection foil
for the separation reagent and you place
the plate
into the instrument next step
is adding a capillary cartridge with 25
empty capillaries into the jazz
instrument
you close the door and you start the run
after three hours you get your data with
high precision
and reputation but what happens what
happens inside the instrument what
happens
inside the capillary
so the chest instrument separates your
proteins by size
this means our empty capillaries are
first filled with matrices
a separation and a stacking matrix
if you look at the top left corner the
filled arm capillary
if you would rotate this capillary 90
degrees clockwise
you would have the same pattern as a
normal sds gel
stacking and separation
in a second step we load a small amount
of sample into each capillary
after this step we apply electricity
current flow
and the negatively charged proteins move
to the right side
the anode anodic side plus side
whilst running through the matrix they
get separated by size
small molecules run faster than large
ones
this is not new this is how capillary
electrophoresis has worked for decays
the new edit part comes now
our caps have a special proprietary
coding
on the inside of the capillary
by using uv light this coating is
activated and it binds all proteins
next to the wall
in the following wash step we remove
everything
except the covalently bound proteins to
the wall
the empty space inside the capillary is
used to apply
washing stats and the incubation steps
for the immune detection
having a glass capillary we can either
detect the light signal from a
chemiluminescence reaction
or we can excite the fluorescent
secondaries and measure their emission
inside the capillary at the end
we record the images in this the the
results in a series of images over time
with a built-in camera
the following animation should describe
those steps in a more
animated way
simple western amino acids take place in
a capillary
your sample separation matrix stacking
matrix
antibodies and reagents are loaded
automatically from a specially designed
plate
just begins by aspirating the separation
matrix
and then the stacking matrix into each
capillary
next your protein lysate is loaded
and capillaries are lowered to make
contact with running buffer
voltage is applied to enable separation
by molecular weight
once the separation is complete uv light
immobilizes the proteins to the
capillary wall
with proteins now immobilized in the
matrix cleared of the capillary
just starts the immunoprobing process
for chemiluminescent detection samples
are first incubated with the primary
antibody
followed by a secondary hrp conjugate
and finally chemoluminescent substrate
the chemiluminescent reaction is
recorded by a ccd camera in a series of
images over time
for fluorescent detection samples are
incubated with the primary antibody
followed by infrared or near infrared
fluorescent secondary tagged antibodies
excitation of the fluorophores releases
photons
and the emission spectra is detected and
recorded by a ccd camera in a series of
images over time
protein normalization has never been
easier with jazz
just load her protein normalization
reagent into a row of wells on the plate
and she'll take care of the rest the
fluorescent labeled reagent reacts with
amines on proteins
enabling a between capillary comparison
of protein load
best of all jessa's fluorescent
detection capabilities
enable two color protein detection for
multiplexing
on top of protein normalization
so with our technology you get
western plot-like results with a
differentiator
that in our technology you have
much faster time to result
in our platform we are capable to do a
real quantitation
we get a high reputation
we have the possibility to multiplex
meaning detecting
different targets from the same sample
in the same capillary
and you only need a very low amount of
sample
as you could see in the animation we do
offer as well
the in-capillary protein normalization
using a fluorescence probe
taking off the burden from your
shoulders to test and run
several loading controls
at the end of july we will launch this
what we call the replex feature
which you can use as in this case as
well
to detect low abundant targets or low of
our low abundant proteins with a more
sensitive protein labeling reagent
are which is then as well used in the
same capillary
so even you could say that we are
the new kids on the plug our technology
is used to publish frequently
and as you can see on the left side are
the uptake on our technology
is going up you could say day by day
nearly
and um the way
people do publish is pretty similar to
the way
arm you would publish standard
traditional western plot data
it's not a problem and as you can see on
the example i show here
you can even publish it together or
whether
data you already received before having
our technology
by hand so i hope i could give you with
this short introduction
a few on our technology and the benefits
which come with it and now it's my real
real pleasure
to hand over to gary who is showing you
what is possible with our instrument in
a decreator research
fantastic thank you carsten thank you
hannah my name is granny allenby
i'm um i'm a member of aurelio
bioscience
um what i'd like to talk to you about
today is the utilization
of the technology that carson's just
been talking about
and also some of the compounds that are
available from
um topress in order to um
look at protac in
different backgrounds
so i think really carson's covered this
slide so um just
i was just going to describe the
technology but he has done this so well
but i'll just move on
to the next slide so surface to say that
the reason i put this slide in was i
wanted to show
the two readouts that the instrument can
give you
so on the right hand side you can see
what
anybody who's seen western blots in
scientific publications would say
is the typical appearance of a western
blot and really that's a pseudo image
that the instrument produces on the
screen
following a run and thereby gives you an
idea
of the molecular weight of your species
that you're looking at
and also the intensity of that however
on the left-hand side
you can see a graph which on the x-axis
is molecular weight
and on the y-axis is chemiluminescence
and what this gives you is this gives
you
an indication of the amount of protein
juiced by the chemiluminescence and that
you have
in that lane yeah so so we
originally purchased a wes
which gave us the opportunity to just do
chemiluminescence about four or five
years ago
utilized that instrument um quite
significantly
and no more recently at the beginning of
the year we bought a jets
the difference being that jess is the
the sister of wes
and jess really gives you the
opportunity to do both chemiluminescence
and fluorescence so by utilizing a
secondary antibody that's labeled with a
neon infrared dye or an infrared dye
you're able then to both quantities and
multiplex
um two species or more species
in the same in the same lane
so um just to highlight because hannah's
done a really good job with regard to
protac
but just to highlight uh we see this as
a phenomenal
um approach in drug discovery
with the ability to be able to deplete
proteins specifically
from within cell types simply by
utilizing the endogenous machinery
i.e the e3 libase and ubiquitination
within the cell and so what that gives
you the opportunity to do
is to massively deplete if not knock out
all together
and the protein of interest by utilizing
what is a relatively small molecule and
the reason i say relatively
is because often these molecules can be
in the 700 to 1000
molecular weight range um
so in addition to that um if you if we
think about the
dissecting the design of a degree the
molecule
it's really composed of three components
um
the the is binding section uh showing
blue on the left
um which obviously um binds to the
ligase
and brings the uh protein uh of interest
uh cl in close proximity with the light
case by utilizing
the uh molecule which is shown in the
green on the right hand side
so that molecule you would hope
specifically binds
to your protein of interest now the
interesting thing in terms of drug
discovery
is the fact that your protein of
interest doesn't necessarily need to be
an enzyme so you don't need to be
um binding your um the binding side to
the enzyme you could actually
utilize a binding site which is a on the
protein itself
and just by using that drag the protein
to the to the livers
and then in the center is is what people
call a linker domain
so a flexible or aesthetically hindered
section of molecule that really allows
the
the movement of both the ligase and the
um the the target warhead and in order
to find
both species and to allow ubisomation to
occur
so my presentation summary we're going
to discuss really two targets
um cdk9 and cdk6
um and we we obtained two molecules
from the tokrus catalog which are the
thal sms032
and vsj03123 which i'll just refer to as
ck6 and nine degrees
um obviously cdk9 is involved in
in transcription and cdk6 is involved in
the
regulation of cell cycle and so most of
these ends are and both of these
it's probably chinese kindnesses are
particularly important
in cancer and in cancer treatment so
what we're going to show in this
presentation are those responses
from protect molecules the ones i've
mentioned
the impact of incubation time with the
protap molecule of the cells
and what that looks like in terms of
protein degradation
and then and then choosing the right
cell background so
think about uh the therapy area but also
think about the type of cell line that
you want to utilize
to try and exemplar um your prototype
and then really investigating protac
activity
in the presence of of cytohexamide
which obviously would block protein
production
and also in terms of a proteasome
inhibitor
which is then going to prevent the
degradation
despite the ubiquitination it would
prevent the deprivation
of your uh protein or target
and then and then lastly we'll go
through some of the pitfalls some of the
hurdles
and some of the things that we've
encountered whilst we've been doing this
work
um we've really been doing prototype
work over the last 12 to 18 months i
would say
and gained experience as a consequence
so um cdk9 to look at initially
so many of my slides will have the
pseudo blot on the right hand side
and we'll have a graph on the left hand
side
each one of the layers as i would call
them as you can see at the top
is labeled with the treatment so the
first line there is the mso
four hours uh 0.3 nanomolar four hours
of the ck-9 the protas etc go from left
to right so we go from low concentration
to high concentration
from left to right um see cdk9 is in the
chemical
so by that what i mean is that we're
using the luminol and the peroxides
in order to generate a chemiluminescent
signal and what we've done is in each
in each of the lanes we've multiplexed
that with actin
so you can see at the bottom the red um
the red
bar is actually the quantity of actin
which is in each one of these layers
and so we've multiplexed the two in the
one
lane now we utilize the suggest to do
this
because we can do both chemiluminescence
and also fluorescence
so we treated these cells now these
cells are mv 411
cells and then a beta myeloid
on the city of san luis so they're a
suspension cell line um and we treated
those
um with uh loads of high concentrations
of this um cdk9 protocol and as you can
see what happens
is that we we can see two bands in the
um
in lanes but you can see that the lower
band
is is depleted and then it's completely
removed
by uh concentrations in the range of uh
30 nanomolar up to 300 nanomolar
in just four hours so i i really found
this really
startling and quite exciting the fact
that you can completely
deplete a cell in this case of cdk9
within four hours
of treatment with the compound at
relatively
low concentrations um
so if you look at the next slide similar
sort of layout to the slide but in this
case we're using
um the cdk6 protac and what you can see
is that we get about 70 percent of the
cdk6
and knocked down at 30 nanomolar um
above um after after four hours
yeah so so in this case we do have two
bands
a cdk6 upper band a cdk6 lower band that
rounds about 40 kilodaltons
and as you can see it is depleted um it
doesn't completely disappear
it gets knocked down to approximately
0.25
so what we do i should have mentioned in
the last slide but what we do
is that we normalize our data to the
actin bands and the reason for doing
that is obviously because we want to
normalize
in terms of the amount of protein and in
terms of the housekeeping protein
in this case that we're using actin um
every
every cell lysate that we generate we we
run uh we do a bca assay on it
in order to determine what the protein
concentration is and then by knowing
that we balance our protein
concentrations but we utilize the acting
in this case in order to um
get an exact ratio of the amount of
cdk6 and the amount of active and so as
i say you can see here that we
deplete by 70 with this protest after
four hours
in this particular cell line
um fascinatingly and i never thought you
could do this until
until my colleague rachel showed me this
is the fact that you can actually
um draw a graph um which actually looks
like a pretty nice dose response curve
in spite of the fact that you're using
uh western black data
um so what you can see on the left-hand
side
is a normalized cdk9 to actin
um against the concentration of the cdk9
prototype and on the right hand side of
the cdk6 proton
so this is a dc50
plot and you can see that we're in the
range of 11 nanomolar
for cdk9 and 6 nanomolar for cdk6
for the removal of those two particular
proteins really interested from the
point of view
of then trying to rank compounds rank
protests against each other based on
western blotting um
in this case we then went on to look at
the time dependency of the activity of
these compounds
in this case i'm showing cdk9 and we're
comparing
the data that we obtained from four
hours versus the data that we obtained
for 24 hours
in the same cell type these mv-411 cells
and you can see that the dc 50 is
shifted slightly to the right
left with increasing time and basically
we've
increased the potency of our compound
from 11 nanomolar to 2 nanomolar
we do get a little bit of fluctuation
um so each one of these points is
so each one of these points is n of
three
so basically three lanes uh run with the
um run with the
cell rises um and you can see that
um both the prototype activity can
fluctuate with time but also um we seem
to see a bit of a hulk effect
um at the um at the lower concentration
um so that was cdk9
and so what does cdk sit sorry what does
ck9 look like if we compare and contrast
between um two different cell types
so in this case what we're doing here is
we're looking at a background
of either hk293 cells or
mb411 cells now obviously they're
completely different cell types one is
one a suspension um so what you can see
with regards to cdk9
is that this protest also works in
hexels
in addition to working in mb411s um
but it's actually less potent in hexose
in comparison with the mv-411s
but again you can see um we've got actin
in the um in the near infrared channel
which is which is the uh the red the red
bars and you can also see the chemi
luminescence on the cdk9
in the uh in the black bars um so you
still get activity
with this uh protac um for cdk9
in these two different cell types
and if however we look at cdk6
using the cdk6 protap molecule and
compare and contrast between the two
different cell types
what you'll be able to see is that
whilst we can see
uh degradation of cdk6 in the mv-411s
um we don't see any uh degradation
of cdk6 in the htk 2 m3 cells
yeah which seems to suggest um that um
as the compound
doesn't particularly have an effect
after four hours
um in the htk 293 cell line
and that makes you uh consider
what cell type background you should be
working in
when it comes to um looking at your
the activity of your protap molecules
uh and i should also say that in every
case where i present the
data in this way um both the um
the near the near infrared acting and
the cdk6
are multiplexed and measured in the same
in the same way
okay so so to to then move on and look
at some mechanistic data
um so we know that there's a compound
um called epoxy myosin and which is
naturally a can
and is selected for inhibition of the
protein zone and so what that would
result in
is in a blockade of the ability
of the cell to be able to degrade
the um the target protein irrespective
of the presence or absence
of the protag molecule
and also we could obviously use
something like cytohexamine
which is a protein synthesis inhibitor
in order to in order to prevent the
um generation of new protein and now you
know interestingly in terms of biology
cells make proteins for specific reasons
and generally
um there'll be some sort of feedback
loop which will then um
switch off the the protein production
um if the protein this the specific
protein that's done it's
just done its job in the cell um so
in many cases what you'll see is that
when when we show plots or graphs you'll
see that
sometimes it doesn't go to zero
i.e maximum inhibition and the total
lack of protein in the cell
and probably one of the reasons for that
is because
we're degrading the protein that is
present
in the cell over the course of the
incubation time
but at the same time the cell is making
more protein because
that protein is not in high enough
concentration to actually do its job
and to switch off its own
manufacture um
and so so here what we've done is that
we've added the
uh apoxolysin um for four hours
in the presence of the cdk9 protac
in the mv-411 cells yeah
and on the right hand side um
you can just see the the labels of each
one of the lanes
so the first three lanes of dmso are the
second three lanes of dmso
plus uh one micromolar uh apoxamycin
um the third three lanes are our cdk9
compound at a concentration that would
completely degrade or
aid the degradation of cdk9 and in the
last three games it's the same
uh concentration of the protest but in
this case we've also added one
micromolar
the proximizer right and so what you can
see
is that um we get approximately
a with 300 nanomolar cdk9 alone
we get a 90 percent reduction in the
cdk9 however
if we treat with approximation um we can
restore the levels
up to approximately 60 percent of what
they were yeah
so clearly what we're doing here is that
we are
um block we are partially
reasonably blocking the
protein zone in terms of its ability
to be able to degrade ck9 with the
addition
of the approximation and one assumes if
you were to go with a higher
concentration
we may well be able to increase that
however you have to also bear in mind
that approximation
is also pretty toxic and so it's a
balance
between getting the result and killing
yourselves
so this is um similar sort of uh layout
of my slide with regard to cdk6 using
the cdk6
protac again in the mb 411 cells and
again treated for four hours
with both the protac and the apocalypse
yeah
in this case um actually that's a typo
but in this case
um we're using thrones and nanomolar of
the protastic gain
on cdk6 and we're basically by using
that we're basically getting about a 70
percent
knockdown of our cbk sits and then what
you can see
is that treatment with one micromolar
fossa bison
um restores the cdk6 to its full
uh levels yeah now two things i wanted
to point out here
uh the fact that um in comparison with
cdk9
obviously in this case we can restore or
we could prevent the degradation of cdk6
completely
with one micromolar approximation
but then in addition to that if you look
at the the block plot
which is on the right hand side what i
wanted to say
is that each one of those lanes
represents a separate biological
experiment
okay so i haven't cheated
and and taken the same cell lyses and
put it on three times
in three separate lanes that's actually
three separate experiments
uh and three separate lysates that have
been put
one in each of the lanes yeah so what
you can see from that
is that our biological reproducibility
is really nice
yeah and so consequently on the graph on
the right on the left-hand side excuse
me
what you can also see is that we're
plotting the mean of the data plus and
minus the standard deviation
in order to show you that um we get
really nice tight data
actually the same also applies to this
graph the one that you've seen up to
this block
the one that you saw on the slide before
these are three
separate biological experiments so you
can see the the quality of
reproducibility
that we can get from our western blot
data on the west
and in this case on the js instrument
um if we think about blocking protein
production
um then with regards to the
cyclohexamine
so in this case again cdk9 prototype
with mb411s
and we treated them for four hours with
cypherhexamid
yeah and we treated them at 10
micrograms per mil
of cyclohexamine yeah and and what we
can demonstrate
is that um by adding um psychohexamine
we can effectively make the
protac appear to be more potent
so on that basis we get dc50 shifting
from 11 nanomolar
to a dc50 that becomes 1.5 nanomolar
and actually what we what i think what
we're doing here is that we're
preventing
or we are reducing the amount of new
um cdk9 um that kinase that is
manufactured by the cell
in the four hours of treatment and so
you can see
a more profound effect of the protac
in this piece in this slide where we're
looking at cdk6 this time
uh in a in a similar experiment on the
same cells four hours of treatment with
cyclohexamid
but this time with the cdk6 protap but
you know what you can see here is that
we really haven't changed
the um the dc50 of this
this protac and i guess that was sort of
reflected
in in the data that we saw in a couple
of slides previously
where actually the cdk6 compound was
able to
completely wipe out um the amount of
cdk6 in the cell whereas we still had
some
2k9 remaining but then again you know
what i want to point out is that
you know this is western blot data these
are graphs that are drawn
um with western black diesel and so
i think this is really a cool technology
and really is applicable
to uh hits the lead um
screening work and more importantly
um i think you know the utilization of
this technology
um not only with cell lines but also
with primary cells would be really
fascinating
from the point of view of let's say
where you've got blood-borne diseases
and you can therefore isolate pbmcs
or t-cells from the blood and be able to
treat these
um in in in well plates with compounds
and then actually to look at these
changes
that occur um to these proteins
in those cell types which would give you
data that would allow you to think about
um future studies in terms of
um post preclinical
phase one phase two yeah so so
just coming on to issues and problems
and associated and experimental
considerations
so so the first thing is choose a cell
line um
and obviously you want to choose a cell
line especially the appropriate ligase
because there are different warheads
there are different
uh parts of the degrader and that will
bind different ligases
um and so if you're choosing cenoblom or
vhl or one of the others
you want to think about the most
appropriate uh warhead for that
and and also um in terms of the
efficiency
with regard to the degradation um and
the protein zone
so the efficiency with which the
compound interacts
and and the system interacts within that
cell so it could be that it's just a
relatively slow turnover
or relatively quick turnover depending
on the
the biological activity of that
particular cell
um obviously some cell types are more
susceptible
to to protect um one of the things to
consider
is prototype permeability so these are
molecules as i mentioned earlier on that
range from sort of 700 to a thousand
miles away more
so they may actually their their passage
into a cell
may be inhibited by by the chemistry of
the protest
and also one has to really consider
that in terms of medicinal chemistry
most chemists drive
drive their their pay if you like and
their bonus
based on the potency of the compounds
and really don't consider the efficiency
of the compound to remain with the
target so the residency time
um i haven't really seen any data as yet
to think about whether you need
a protest that binds to the libraries
advice at target
and remains there for like five seconds
five minutes
uh five hours in order to do its job
um also um you need to choose someone
that really doesn't manufacture your
target in match quantities
and because if it does you're going to
find it really difficult
to be able to observe a knockdown so
i can't we kind of think about like cell
types being in the goldilocks zone
so they really want to have a lit you
know not too much not too little
and just right when it comes to the
amount of protein that they manufacture
which you're trying to
decrease uh also you can't bear in mind
the fact that
protaps can be toxic in themselves
and by that what i mean is that we've
we've had studies in the past where
people have gone for
proteins that are targets at the the top
of the biological cascade
and so by removing those proteins
um actually then what happens is that
the cell becomes
pretty pretty um dead pretty quickly
um because obviously before you're
removing something which is very
essential
to the topical biological cascade um
also what we tend to know that certain
protests have worked
is they have very low bta protein
content
and also if you look down the microscope
you have excuse my french
but they look pretty crap down the
microscope in terms of their appearance
um and then um you have to really assess
different
protest incubation times and
concentrations in order to minimize that
toxicity
because there's nothing you know there's
nothing wrong with trying to use a
protest that kills a cell
um if you were saying looking at a
cancer target in ecology
oncology etc but you'd have to come up
with some means of being selective
and only killing that cell in comparison
with obviously
the ones that you don't want to kill um
so
last but not least um loading control so
loading controls are
really important and we've i've shown
most of the data today has been shown
with acting
um but we have done different loading
controls
um you can sometimes see that um
the toxicity which is created by the
effects that you're having on the cell
with the front
can result in toxicity that results in a
change
in your loan control which isn't really
what you want because if you're trying
to raise your
billing control your loan control is
changing
then you're gonna have issues um and
also
you know cell treatments like
approximation
can have effects on on your motion
controls
so so what we're just showing here is
actually
a near infrared uh plot
of in these mv-411 cells when we treated
uh with apostomycin and so what we get
um in the absence of apostomatin is is
an amount of actin
that produces somewhere in the region
about ten thousand
uh near infrared units um however
if we add our uh one micro more the
proximation
then we can deplete that by forty
percent
so the level's going down to six
thousand so bear that in mind
if you're trying to use that as your uh
ratio that's your to ratio to that
because obviously that will affect your
uh data and your target protein
um and those measurements um second
thing
is as i said that protests can cause
toxicity so in this case what you can
see
is that you can see a four hour
treatment with the cdk9
protac on the left hand side after four
hours
either 100 or 300 nanomolar
doesn't show any variability or
variation in the actin
um however in comparison on the right
hand side in those three lanes which are
after 24 hours
you can see dmso looks the same but the
100 or 300 nanomolar cdk9
prototype actually depletes the active
yeah
and so that is probably um a consequence
of the effect that the prototype have is
having in general
on your cell population
um next next thing is that really
um the different targets that we've
looked at
target protein and motion controls so
we've looked at hsp 60
we've looked at tubulin we've looked at
vinculin
etc and so really you need to
uh i guess test your protac against
these
different um loading control proteins
in order to make sure that they don't
have a significant
effect um before using them to ratio
your data to
again um we had as i said in the
beginning of my presentation we've had
we had uh wes for about four or five
years
um but what we struggled with was to
multiplex
um a chemiluminescence rebound for our
loading protein
with a chemiluminescent result for our
target protein and there's two reasons
for that
one was because you know sod's law says
that the
molecular weight of your target protein
is going to be the same or they're about
to your loan control so they're going to
super impose on one another
or secondarily that when you come to do
it your motion control
is so high in terms of protein
concentration
that it completely utilizes all of your
luminol and peroxide substrate and so it
doesn't interact with your target
and you just end up with a blob and so
if you then try and decrease or decrease
the amount of protein that you add to
your
wefts you can see a
a decrease in let's say you're acting
but you will completely
remove your target protein because
you've had to dilute it let's say
tenfold
in order to get a decent um blot um
and so um we actually then moved as a
consequence of that to jess
because that gave us the opportunity to
run
multiplex assays where we basically
utilize both hemi luminescence generally
for our target protein
and fluorescence generally for our
motion control
okay uh constantly just mentioned this
and i just wanted to mention this as
well
you can do protein normalization so left
hand side came in luminescence
um same block the middle of the slide is
neon infrared fluorescence
and then the far right is protein
normalization
um and so that does give you the
opportunity then
to actually be able to normalize the
total amount of protein the software
will do that
the total amount of protein that you put
in each lane and then you could utilize
that as well if you wanted to
however we we run bca assays
on each sample and we don't feel like um
we really need to do that
and also i mentioned cell backgrounds
you have to bear that in mind
and use a therapeutically relevant cell
line so what i'm showing here
on the left hand side is um data
that was generated in one cell type or
one cell line
and on the right hand side due to that
was generated
another cell type of cell line and you
can see that
um that the compound with the well one
compound intricacies
and with the three arrows uh pointing at
it is actually the same compound
which shows activity at that
concentration in that particular cell
line
the same compound on the left hand side
shows no activity
in the other cell line so you have to
bear in mind the cell
themselves that you're looking at um
next you have to also think about the
target location so where your protein
is actually exists in the cell and
whether it's in the membrane it's in the
nucleus or whether it's in the cytoplasm
and that will influence the way you
disrupt the cells
in order to get the protein hours and so
sometimes we use ripper buffer
and sometimes we use mp40 lysis buffer
and sometimes we use tris triton it
really depends on
where the target is the target protein
and
um the extraction processes of you to
extract it
in order to measure it you can see on
the right hand side
we're comparing your target on in
a ripper buffer a ripper license buffer
versus mp40 license buffer
and you can see with regards to mp40
license buffer you hardly see any target
whereas you can see you see a lot of
target with regard to the utilization of
ripple buffer probably because that
target
um last but not least think about the
hook effect that can occur
in protac so by that what i mean is i'm
showing a little
not animation but a little graph on the
left hand side so
really what you want is you want sort of
the right uh stochiometry between your
compounds
and your target so you know a little bit
of compound with a lot of target
means that you're going to get
degradation and you're going to get the
formation of
of complexes appropriate complexes
binary complexes
between your target your mouth and your
compound if you add too much compound
then what tends to happen is that you
end up with rather than ending up with
tertiary complexes
you probably end up with criteria
complexes where some of the
molecules where some of the compound is
bound to the target and some of the
compound is bound
to the ligands and because
they're occupying those sites they
actually can't come together
and cause um close proximity
and so what we showing on the right hand
side there is where we've seen that
where um as you increase the amount of
uh compound
it appears as though you see more
targeting comparison of the control
and that's basically this um
um last but not least i wouldn't be um
the
um the managing director of really
bioscience if i didn't give us a plug
so really bioscience on a small contract
research organization we're small but
we're beautifully formed and we
we live in nottingham which is in the
center of the uk
um we we uh have a number of different
biological technologies we're not a
chemistry company we do biology
and we have another member of different
biological technologies
within our laboratories in order to
design bespoke
um tailored assay uh formats both cell
and by biochemical based in order to do
our work
we have our access to phlebotomist which
means that we have
um access to blood on site have access
to an animal house so we can do an xb
most of these
and we've worked we've been in business
now for the last nine years
um i have recently worked at astrogenics
and prior to that years clearly prior to
that hot on the road
so um yeah so we've been round the block
more than once
um so actually that's me finished
and i'd like to say a big thank you to
my colleagues who's been sitting next to
me and prodding me along
which is my colleague rachel dr rachel
deutsch
who i call the queen of western blotting
um rachel
um did a lot of western blotting in her
previous job
using the old equipment that carsten
mentioned
and when she joined aurelia and we
introduced it to west and jazz
um it's now she has two children and the
instruments have now become a fair child
um so so she really she really sees the
value in the instrument the technology
and then i'd like to thank hannah um for
um
from talkers for uh organizing the
webinar
together with um the people who we
utilize in the uk the most which is peru
who's the account manager and elaine who
is actually the field application
scientist in the uk so the details there
that's me
um if you want to have a look at our
website or get in touch please do so
um thank you for listening and i'll now
hand you back to the
lab roots i'd like to thank them for
organizing
thank you
thank you very much gary for the great
presentation
uh we will now go on to the live q a
portion of the webinar
we have just a few minutes left if you
have
a question that you'd like to ask please
feel free to do so now
you can just click on the ask the
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and we'll answer live as many questions
as we have time for
um and then following the webinar any
questions that we haven't answered
um we will um answer by email with the
contact details that you've provided
so to kick off there's a question here
which actually i have the same question
um so we'll start with that so this is
perhaps one
for gary um on slide 23 there was a
an increase shown in the cdk9 levels
after treatment with the lower
concentrations of the protac
compared to dmso control and
i think there was a comment that the
effect was due to ternary complex
formation
it was just an interesting effect would
be good to get your comments on
um whether that that's a real effect and
whether you have any comments on yes
that's the correct side
so yeah whether you have any comments on
on what that might be due to
yeah no thanks hannah you've stopped us
i'm sorry guys
um uh i mean protects do
do have a tendency to do this sometimes
where where there's
almost not enough prototype potentially
it's binding
in low concentrations and it's almost
blocking
um the protease inhibitor the proteases
but not i don't know it's it's yeah it's
we're not quite sure where we have this
one
yeah yeah i think if you mean this
yeah anyway if you mean
the fact that it seems to go higher than
sort of the dmso control
i all we can think it is that is that
the protest binding
to the protein causes some sort of
stabilization and
and thereby
we almost like at low concentrations end
up
with um more protein
because the protein has been has banned
the protag
and is almost like stabilized because
we've seen that
we've seen it before with other targets
not only cdk9 and cdk6 but other things
as well
and it's not it's not a it's not a um
an effect which is a consequence of the
acting or the lonesome control
it also might be that we've we've bound
the cdk9 and it's
become inactive because this big
molecule is now stuck to it
and so the cells notice that and it's
increased its expression of it and
try and compensate for the fact that
it's no longer active
even though it's still present the thing
is that all of them i always think you
know that
cells don't make proteins unless there's
a reason to do it
and and also but also a protein will
tend to feed back on itself
once it's done its job or some some
other mechanism
will feed back on itself in order to
inhibit if you like the manufacture of
more protein
and so so sometimes i think what we're
seeing there is possibly
a sort of a disruption of the feedback
loop yeah
because we know city council i think is
quite rapidly expressed as when we
treated with
cyclohex we shifted the uh the dc 50
question quite a bit
yeah so it must be quite quickly turned
over yeah
so if we have disruptive speed but we
might be able to see that
there's a concentration yeah thank you
both
yeah it'd be interesting maybe to
compare actually to the cdk9 inhibitor
alone and um
and look at that effect but yeah thank
you that's that's an interesting point
we are running out of time
and so i think we just have time for one
other question
and we have um this one in and perhaps
this is one maybe more for carsten to
answer
um and the question is when there is
interference among the antibody for
the housekeeping protein and the target
protein
is it acceptable if the housekeeping
protein is run in the same sample and
different capillary
hello here this is are indeed
acceptable because in comparison to
western plots
are the instrument itself always takes
this kind of 50 nanoliters
out of each well of your sample
and even if you would have not proper
calibrated
pipettes meaning you would pipette let's
say three microliters
four microliters five microliters from
your sample in wealth
next to each other you would get the
same result
so on our technology it is
let's say um possible to
load your sample in different wealth and
compare them
amongst each other and in there the same
way there was a
similar question according like um why
don't you use um hrp coupled secondaries
for
target and loading control which goes in
a similar direction
quite often your loading control has a
much higher
abundancy arm as your target
and even if you got a huge linear range
it might be that your loading control
is way too much in those samples and
then you do it the way
gary nicely showed you swap over or
for your loading control in the near
infrared channel
which are is a little bit less sensitive
but by doing so you have the possibility
to
detect both together in the same
capillary
yeah great thanks awesome yeah i think
we would second that i mean
you know when we're doing a protest um
we
typically would use six well plates and
maybe put between half a million and a
million cells
in the well um and then um you know we
tend to
um sell lines that may be 100
microliters of
cell lysis um and then but you only
really utilize
at best like two microliters of that in
each plane
but then you might have to dilute your
protein off to tenfold
in order to do that something was like
with a chemi with the chemist signal
so for cdk9 i'll probably need to load
one ml 0.5 ml protein to pick that up
nicely and chemi
but if i try to detect actin at that
protein concentration
i'd probably get a million chemicals and
it would be off the scale
so that's why we end up having to switch
to um
the fluorescence channel for the loading
controls because it was just you
couldn't get the hemi signal
of the target and loading control in the
right range
for that procedure okay great thanks
thank you both
for that answer i'm i'm aware we are um
coming out of time
so i'd like to thank um the speakers
today for their time and and the
interesting research that was presented
i'd also like to thank lab roots
uh for hosting the webinar today um and
also to the audience for joining us
and for your attention and interesting
questions there are a number of
questions we didn't have time to answer
and those will be answered post webinar
via email
lab routes will be alerting you via
email when this webinar is available for
replay and we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who
might have missed today's live event
and with that thank you all for
listening and until next time goodbye